It's a mistake if you don't love me. I'll set
you free and make you realize your true feelings.
[Music]
Why don't you
give up on that person? She's my bride. I wo
n't abandon you.  That's what I
said.Also, I'm going to throw it from the tower.Thank you
very much.Please, that guy's head must have jumped.My
skeletons.Catch them.I've
got the rights.Now, that's
all for your misdeeds.I'm
ready.  The
magic crystal from back then was a heirloom of my family. I wonder
if he committed the crime after peeking into someone else's bones and awakening to his special fetish. This perverted scumbag
is Toglas.
[Music] I
thought you could do it just with my magic power, you perverted
scumbag.